hey guys welcome to the session on RBA
tools in this video we are going to
compare the most commonly used RBA tools
namely blue prism uipath an automation
anywhere so what's in it for you first
we learn why exactly RBA came into
picture and then what exactly RB is
lastly we'll compare the tools based on
trial version based technologies process
designer accessibility macro recorders
architecture learning robots accuracy
reusability pricing and then
certification so without further ado
let's begin and understand why was RBA
introduced
consider the process of onboarding or
recruit your organization the whole
process will involve tasks like creating
a new user account a new email address
access rights documents retrieval and so
on so influent doing all of this
manually one can automate the process so
with our PA the user can automatically
activate a template for the onboarding
workflow our PA can help assess prepare
and create new joinee data initiate
mailing of offer letters and streamline
the information across different systems
so what is RBA robotic process
automation is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle
high-volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans to perform
now some of these tasks could include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
now our de tools are the software
through which one can configure tasks
that are to be automated so some of the
widely used tools are uipath studio
automation anywhere blue prism work
fusion among others
now assuming you have a basic
understanding of RTA let's go on and
compare the popularly used tools first
up is trial version every tool generally
offers a trial version for its users to
get acquainted with the GUI this helps
the users understand the tool better and
decide if they want to proceed with
using the tool blue prism offers a free
trial version it's available in two
options either on the cloud all on the
local computer you iPad also offers a
free edition both trial and license
versions are available automation
anywhere offers a free community version
and both Trier and license versions are
available next up is based apologies
based technologies define the technology
with which the software was built blue
prism is based on c-sharp uipath is
based on Microsoft vendors like
SharePoint cabana and elasticsearch
while automation anywhere is based on
modern Java technologies the third
feature of comparison is process
designer blue prism enables you to
create design edit as well as test
business processes from the visual
business object now o BB o is like an
adapter provided by blue prism for
communicating with an application each
visual business object implements a
specific set of obligations on an
applications user interface so these are
basically like objects that encapsulate
a particular functional logic UI path on
the other hand acts as a visual process
designer with developer friendly options
now a visual process designer is a
dashboard consisting of various tools
through which the developer can define
the automation tasks Automation anywhere
is developer friendly with the visual
interface built for business users along
with advanced features for developers
business users and developers can work
side by side to build BOTS
they can see the visual interface and
code in a single screen the next feature
of comparison is accessibility blue
prism offers browser-based access only
ey paths and automation anywhere on the
contrary offer both application based
and browser-based
accessibility in case of automation
anywhere the control room can be
accessed with a browser or a mobile
application this is the only platform
where users can create BOTS on any
device or any operating system moving on
to the next feature learning now in case
of blue prism the user should have the
necessary knowledge for programming he
should be able to create business
objects and manage them in the control
center uipath enables you to design
automation processes visually through
type-ins the developer need not know
programming language in particular when
it comes to automation anywhere it is
developer friendly and offers both
visual and programming features business
users can build BOTS with the help of
drag and drop features beginners benefit
from the built-in product walkthrough
next up is robots now before jumping
let's discuss what the different types
of bots are literally types of words we
have the front of his pots whose
deployment isn't the users control he
also had back of his pots that can run
on blocked machines from an Orchestrator
the user may not be actively involved in
it's working so moving on to the
comparison blue prism offers back of his
automation only UI path an automation
anywhere offer both front and back
office automation in case of automation
anywhere the HVC
or the human bought collaboration
feature enables humans and BOTS to work
together to complete a task and also to
manage exceptions and escalations
moving on the next feature is macro
recorder now the macro recorder allows
you to record keyboard activities and
mouse events to generate automation
scripts these activities are arranged
based on the order or sequence of
actions being performed on the screen so
moving on to the comparison blue prism
does not use a macro recorder
uipath meets use of a macro recorder to
enable fast process mapping automation
anywhere offers Universal recorder so
that the user need not select different
recorders for different tasks moving on
to the next feature architecture an
application that runs on the client side
and accesses the remote server for
information uses the client-server
architecture whereas an application that
runs entirely on the web browser uses
the web architecture in case of a
client-server architecture the user
interaction with the server is always
through a user interface for application
on the client side on the other hand in
a web application the user interaction
is thoroughly through a web browser now
blue prism and uipath both incorporate a
client-server architecture automation
anywhere incorporates a cloud needs a
web-based microservices architecture it
is the only platform that provides a
complete digital worker solution on the
web users with any skill level can
instantly start building robots on a
browser without any heavy installation
the next feature is accuracy blue prism
is accurate for desktop web and Citrix
automation uipath shines in citrix
automation design could be be automation
an automation anywhere shines insert its
automation with a I sense technology
well any automation solution built using
a virtual desktop or built to work in
virtual desktops this call citrix
automation moving on to the next feature
reusability blue prism consists of a
library of business objects that can be
reused across multiple methods
it also offers high reliability in the
case of uipath the processes can be used
for various synthesis services with
several workflow modules as a result
uipath offers a high degree of usability
and moderate reliability in the case of
anywhere apart from the standard common
library users can develop custom actions
upload and manage packages in the
enterprise control room every pot
created in automation anywhere is
reusable the bot store has hundreds of
pre-configured BOTS and digital workers
to kick-start a user's rph journey
next up is pricing blue prism has a high
cost of acquisition
it also offers restricted cleaning
uipath offers effective Pleasant
entry-level pricing automation anywhere
offers attractive entry level pricing
its users also experience the lowest
total cost of ownership because of its
native capabilities and web-based
architecture
moving on to the last feature
certifications blue Prizm offers several
certifications like blue prism
professional developer blue prism rom
architect among others
ey part provides free online training
and certification programs like our PA
developer advanced certification
automation anywhere university offers
free online training and certification
programs for both students and advanced
practitioners professionals can also
avail
job roles specific certifications there
are settl RTA tools in the market today
however blue prism automation anywhere
and uipath are leading the market so
with that we come to the end of this
session I hope the video helped you gain
a clearer picture of the three tools
make sure to LIKE the video if you
enjoyed it also subscribe to our Channel
and hit the bell I came to never miss an
update I'm going to see you guys next
time until then keep learning and stay
tuned to simply long hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos Dinard up and get
certified click here